you were involved very much involved I
remember when construction broke at the
Trump International Hotel will you give
up your stake in the hotel I my stake in
the hotel is part of a trust and I
manage any conflict that comes up so
basically how they break up the the
issues is is this likely to cause a
conflict or is it a manageable conflict
in which case you can retain your
interest but you have the obligation to
recuse yourself
so penny pritzker for example served in
the Obama administration and she
maintained massive portfolio of assets
but the burden was on her to recuse
herself from potential conflict so I'm
not going to be involved with talking
about leases we had the General Services
Administration because that could
potentially create a conflict for me so
I understand the obligation on me to
avoid conflicts of interest and this is
I take that serious this is a concern I
keep hearing about the hotel over and
over again that the family may not be
involved but you could see foreign
leaders coming and saying I'm gonna stay
at the Trump Hotel I might even take a
towel or two with the Trump name on it
because they think that that would curry
favor with your with your father do you
not see that being an issue well the law
is very specific on conflict of interest
I would have to instruct somebody to
stay there I would have to know about
who is staying there and tell them to
pay more than fair market value and you
know so it's it's it's a manageable
thing so I don't know where people are
staying if they are staying there I'm
sure they're not telling me why they're
staying there and I would never push
somebody to stay there so so no I I
don't and I think I'll I think just
generally you can create so many
hypotheticals around how someone could
benefit or not benefit and all I can do
is follow the guidance of outside
counsel who told me how to structure
these assets based on fact pattern and
the people who advised us our career
within these offices they deal with
every administration they're not
Republican appointees and
and and they lay out a framework for
which we restructured all of our
holdings so there anyone else in any
other administration